Mr. David Pacman out of the debate of it. He had an event coming
up with uh Destiny in Detroit. David Pacman will not be joining
us for June 22nd in Queens. It is now a solo show like in Detroit.
Destiny did a thing. Had he done it before being famous, it would
have surfaced once he was. I guess it's just the way it is when
you were a celebrity. You have to bear the weight of every of
your mistakes because people can't get over internet drama. Crap.
Crap. Internet drama.
to it. He admitted to it. He admitted to it. He admitted to it.
He signed a sword statement. He signed a statement saying he
did it. Ah. Ah.
People that were asking, "How the does your motherboard not have
the it's a mini ITX?" Some of those just don't have them to save
the space.
And I didn't realize cuz I'm a dumb.
Okay. I don't know how it was working at all is the question,
but it was. But it had like really like fuzzy god. I don't
Okay. All right. So guys, the first thing we're going to cover
is listen, we're not going to cover lawsuit stuff as much. We're
not going to be as close on that. But one thing that is a little
bit funny is apparently um Oh, is this not going to load now?
No, it loaded.
Apparently Mr. David Pacman out of the debate of it. He had an
event coming up with Destiny in Detroit. David Pacman will not
be joining us for June 22nd in Queens. It is now a solo show
like in Detroit. So I don't I guess they're in Queens or Hold
on. Let me find uh somebody gave me an image of
file. Is that it? No, that's not it. That's it. Okay, this one.
So, the Pangurn guy put out a statement. Let's Let's read it.
Official statement from Pangburn regarding June 22nd event in
Queens, New York. We regret to inform our audience and ticket
holders that David Pacman has chosen to withdraw from his scheduled
appearance at the anti-Trump tour event on June 22nd, 2025 at
the Queens Theater in New York, where he was set to appear alongside
Destiny. Prior to signing his contract, David was fully informed
of the event details, including some public accusations that
Destiny's currently defending himself against. With full knowledge
of these circumstances, David agreed to participate and signed
his contract, allowing us to proceed with a formal public announcement
and ticket sales. On May 9th, shortly after the announcement
was made, David informed us that he had received some negative
feedback regarding his participation. Despite previously indicating
that he was not troubled by this and suggesting that the negative
feedback may have been instigated by agitators, David and his
team later cited reputational concerns as they their reason for
backing out. These concerns were not raised until after the event
had already been publicly announced, contracts signed, and tickets
sold. We want to be clear, Pangurn takes its contractual obligations
seriously. We do not move forward with announcing events until
all agreements are legally confirmed in order to protect our
attendees, speakers, and organizations from unnecessary disruptions.
Many of our attendees take time off work, book flights and accommodations,
and make personal sacrifices to attend our events. It is our
responsibility to honor these commitments. Those
commitments. All right. Although David's team requested to be
released from his contractual obligation, we express that from
both a legal and ethical standpoint, the professional course
of action would be for him to honor the agreement. This situation
underscores the importance of due diligence before signing any
contract. Despite our attempts to find a resolution, on May 15th,
David formally notified us that he would not be appearing at
the event. As a result, we will be transitioning the Queen's
event into a solo one with Destiny against Trump supporters.
Uh, we understand some may be disappointed, blah blah blah blah
blah blah. Anyway, Pac-Man basically was like, "Oh, I uh I don't
know." And the the funny thing is is Pangurn is it seems like
he's saying here that, "Hey, we told him all about Destiny's
accusations
and he decided to come anyway." So now I would love to see what
made Pac-Man drop out. If Pac-Man knew all of the facts, then
why did he drop out? I think the likelihood that he knew all
of the facts is incredibly unlikely. I'm sure that some stuff,
right? But I highly doubt David Pacman sat there and listened
to a 2-hour long Ryan Beard video on top of everything else,
right? I I think it's would be impossible for him to know everything.
Well, I'm just saying that if they're going to come and blow
him up publicly and say like he lied to us basically, then I'd
love to see what he was told and what he could have been told
after that to make him change his mind, right? Cuz I feel like
probably for me, Pac-Man probably didn't get the whole story.
And then when he did get the whole
story, but he when he did get the whole story, maybe he was like,
"Oh, wait, never mind. That's not cool."
I just I would I'm not suggesting um I'm not suggesting this
other company were like intentionally misleading or anything.
I just think there's quite a lot of information a person would
have to absorb and the likelihood that him or his team would
have done that feels quite low. I don't
know. And you could criticize them for that, I guess, not doing
their due diligence before signing a contract, right? But I'm
sure he's a busy guy that does this quite a lot and is willing
to take the L on whatever was in the contract that has a negative
to him. I have no clue what. Yeah. Well, I just think it's interesting
that they basically they basically just said he he knew everything
and and he agreed anyway and then he totally he backed out for
no reason is basically what they're saying. Like no change.
Yeah, that seems kind of um I mean that's one way for people
to never want to work with you in the future as well, right?
It's like, oh, if we drop out because of pretty valid reasons,
right? I'm going to get shamed by this company, so why why the
would I want to work with them in the future?
Yeah. Which
pang burn people are. Who are they? Yeah. Well, they said his
own PR team cited negative response uh responses after the fact.
Not that he changed his mind for no reason. Sure. But what what
Pangurn is saying is we informed him of this. So obviously even
if his PR team said or or does it say PR team? It might say PR
team. It it just says his team, right? Let me see here.
He David informed us he'd received some negative feedback. So
that's like fine or whatever, but I'm guessing that if he knew
all everything that had happened, I would assume that if he was
fully informed, then he would have said, "Oh, well, I knew about
that,
right?" What? Destiny got roasted in the comments. Uh the comments
on the subreddit or somewhere else? Oh, here. Hold on. What What
platform is this on? Pang burn. I don't even know what platform
this is on, but link that Ry if you've got it because I was going
to go through some of the subreddit posts. They're they're pretty
funny. Surprised Dpack agreed to this in the first place. Same.
I was pleasantly There's a lot of very funny comments in here
in his own Reddit. Oh. Oh, yeah. Sure, sure, sure. Yeah. Was
pleasantly surprised that he decided to attend, but until the
court situation is settled, I don't expect him to be debating
many big personalities. This court case keeps going the way it's
sounding. Things like this could demonstrate actual damages for
a defamation counter suit by virtue of the improper way Pixie
and their team proceeded with everything. This is completely
delusional.
My god, this is delusional. It's amazing.
Uh, what was that? That was Bazooka Tooth with two months. Thank
you very much, Bazooka Tooth. Was that over on Twitch? That's
a primer. That was a primer. Thank you very much, Bazooka Tooth.
Appreciate you. So, I'm sorry. This is just very funny to me.
the whole uh this
this where where who are you suing for defamation and where's
the defamation? What have they said that's a
lie? There's literally nothing in any of their stuff that is
a lie. I just
the
right? I people just throw around the word defamation without
understanding it one iota. It's very strange most of the time.
me.
Anyway, so what else do we get? Genuinely curious if anyone might
know, although I highly doubt it. Would it be possible to cite
these damages to the judge that they make Pixie's lawyers hurry
the up with the suit since they can't compensate? Who's not hurrying
up with the suit? What damages are they talking about? The guy
not joining is destiny making money off this event.
Uh yeah, I he must be making some money off this event or something.
But maybe just the reputational concerns in general. Other people
have reputational concerns.
Oh, hold on. What was that? Uh, Obsidian, thank you very much
for the primer. We got a hype train going on
Crazy. So, none of these things that cause damages were false
statements of fact from Pixie. 99% of the damages Steven shared
by nudes non-conensually, which he probably couldn't counter
sue over. Yeah. Oh my god, there's Amazing.
It would only be defamation if Destiny was found not guilty.
He is not in a criminal trial with Pixie, so he could not be
found not
guilty. The real Dr. Cube, you understand that, right? He'd be
found not liable, but I I don't think these are like findings
of fact, right? They don't prove intent. He could then sue for
defamation for accusing intent. No, that is not accusing you.
You can't be sued for your opinions against a public figure.
That's an
opinion. Yeah. Anyway,
uh this is very funny though. Overall, probably not a good look
for Pack to debate someone he thinks has autism. Ah.
Ah. Not to glaze too. Sorry. This this was funny. Not to glaze
too hard here, but is Destiny the only creator capable of having
a spine with his community? I feel like everyone is just constantly
getting down by their audiences. What the like are we really
going to compare this to Dean Parker? David David Pacman not
wanting to to partner with somebody who's accused of multiple
crimes and versus Dean Parker like nexting somebody for nothing.
It's not remotely the same thing. It's not even close. Didn't
that Dena and Parker girl actually go on
That's uh I just
Yeah, I don't know. I am Am I crazy or is it just not obviously
bad to send materials to other people of your partners, your
friends, your co-workers, all these people without their consent?
It just seems like that's probably bad. Like that's probably
already something people are like, "Oh, this guy's kind of a
weirdo."
It is in fact very bad. Yes, people are very victim blamy. It
seems it's not very obvious to shockingly. You forgot about Trump.
What about Trump? What about Trump? We need to delete Trump.
Uh, hold on. Let me keep I just clicked on this routine. God
damn it. I do find it funny that Destiny's subre is going after
Pac-Man for this. Let me keep checking these. Destiny gets all
his opinions directly from me, too. I don't care about this one
anymore. Receive some negatives feedback. Cited reputational
concerns. Well, audience capture is a thing regardless of this
side. This the side. Not sure how he didn't see it coming beforehand,
though. Pack doesn't really follow. Audience capture,
I think. Uh, so audience capture, what would this mean? Yeah,
I guess just doing what your audience says here. Meaning audio
cap
capture. I think that's a
stretch. Okay. only dropping at an
Oh, this was funny though. Hold on. Uh, Pack doesn't follow really
follow the drama Destiny. I think I remember someone mentioning
the drama to him in a live stream and he seemed to not really
care or brush it off at the time. He could have just recently
be made aware of the details by people trying to ruin the event
and his team probably recommended go against going. It is what
it is. And it's like, okay.
Uh, I don't think informing people who are collabing with Destiny
that they might not have the whole story is trying to ruin events.
No, he knew it's the same story as the canvasing. Or was it protesters
thing there? He thought he could bear it, but when his audience
complained, he realized he didn't fully understand the impact/backlash
backslash and folded. Not blame him, but I thought he understood
this better. Uh, again, maybe that's true. I just don't think
so. But yeah, David Pacman pulled out of the the debate event
he was going to be doing with Destiny. So, we're just reading
some of the code. Majority 77, thank you for the
The majority of people that are within the community don't know
the full details of everything. Right. So, the idea that David
Pacman knows, I mean, just think of the amount of people that
we've had come on stream and they're just like completely oblivious
to half of the details. And those are people that are actively
around. So yeah. Yeah.
Oh, this was this was a good one. Saw this one. Destiny needs
to start thinking about what he's going to do to stabilize his
reputation once the court stuff settles. It really seems like
he thinks once this is over as usual and ignore the haters. If
he were to go to court and defeat the allegations as they stand
directly, then that could be true. But if it gets thrown out
on summary judgment because of the date the law went into effect
or whatever, then he just won on a technicality arguments will
hold a lot of water and everything he does will be swarmed with
comments about his allegations with nothing to point out to point
to disproving them. It just might be the worst outcome reputationally.
He'll need some kind of definitive statement on what exactly
he did and did not do wrong and that he that he can stand behind
if he wants to move forward in that kind of resolution. Well,
luckily for us, Destiny already gave a a uh what do you call
it? an affidavit saying that he'd never shared the pixie video
after he shared it to Rose, but that he did in fact share the
pixie video to Rose. So, he's already admitted to it. We don't
even need to know. He doesn't have to be found liable for any
damages here to know that the actual behavior was engaged in.
That's the funny thing. There's nothing about like people lying.
There's no lying going on here, right? He's admitted to
it. Okay. The people criticizing won't listen. They still think
he supports.
That's not true. I don't think anything Destiny does or says
will change people's mind on the the on the matter at this point.
He literally went through all the court stuff on stream and explained
everything he could. Did anyone change their already established
opinions of him? No, because the already established opinions
were based on the material facts. Nobody Here's the thing with
a lot of DJers. They're basing their opinion on like Destiny's
characterization of Pixie's lawyers. I don't I don't know because
I'm not a lawyer. So, I've I've said the whole time maybe they'll
get like uh you know, maybe they'll get not a citation. Maybe
they get reprimanded or something. Maybe, but like the the actual
material facts are in and they're not good for him. A sanction.
Yes, a
sanction. Reality we live in, but the mere fact that Destiny
was sued over something is enough for people to hold No, he admitted
to it. He admitted to it. He admitted to it. He admitted to it.
He signed a sword statement. He signed a statement saying he
did it.
Ah. Destiny did a thing. Had he done it before being famous,
it would have surfaced once he was. I guess it's just the way
it is when you were a celebrity. You have to bear the weight
of every of your mistakes because people can't get over internet
drama. Crap.
Crap. Drama.
Jacob 903. Thanks for the primer. Appreciate it. Damn.
That's huge. I just can't get over it.
Well, the funny thing is is like he assaulted Mia Rose on his
stream and he's had a career this whole time despite that, right?
He literally did revenge porn or hold on, not revenge porn. He
non-consensually leaked somebody's nudes before this and he had
a whole career, right? So I what are we doing here that we're
trying to pretend that Desi was held back by drama? It's like
once he was 33, 34, 35, he was doing these insanely degenerate
things like sharing people's
mutually recorded with him without their consent to randoms.
Right? That's that's the problem is this is like a fully formed
adult. It wasn't like little mistakes he made when he was immature.
It's like a fully formed adult doing things with full
knowledge. The blue te Well, hold on. The blue tea thing was
revenge in the other direction. Wait, I don't think it was revenge.
I think he was sharing it and talking [__] I don't
think it was revenge in that case. It was definitely non-consensual
sharing, though.
Uh, I came back after this. It is not useless, but I had been
a fan for 10 years before the lawsuit. I doubt the Twitter mob
even cares about the explanation. I would love to know what this
guy thinks again. How are characterizations of Pixie's lawyers
and Destiny saying these people lie? How is that? I don't understand
how that changes people's opinion on the base level facts. Like
I sorry, I understand rhetorically how it like gives people something
to hold on to because a lot of DJs just wanted to be back in
DG no matter what. But um like I totally understand that it's
like their life raft, right? It's their their flotation device
cuz they're drowning. Without that is their like social engagement.
I totally get it. But what I don't understand is like on an actual
logical level, how would this make a
difference? Uh
okay. Isn't that the point? Can you think of anyone losing their
career for spreading nudes or videos? I just Yeah. Bob 7.
Bob 7 literally had his career destroyed by Destiny over this
exact thing. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Hello. Is this Hello?
Hello? Who are you yelling at? Is this on? Is this
Okay. Okay. All right. What else are we doing here? Oh, I'm still
reading comments. I'm I just find a lot of these like fascinating.
It's sort of like borderline self harm to go and read it though
and but it it feels fun or it feels very funny to go and read
it at the same
time. Hold on. What did Box Society say? It's true. I've listened
to the vids that Ryle put out read court docs and was surprised
how important his tone is when reading plus the insertion of
an unhinged for extra flavor. Well, like here's the thing. Um
I did listen to a third party. Apparently Pixie people should
be doing more in terms of filings. Like they should be amending
their complaint. There's a bunch of stuff they should be filing,
but from my point of view, unless they were specifically like
telling Abby not to sign an affidavit until the very last moment,
it seems like she just had signed the affidavit at the very last
moment and as soon as they had it, they went forward. If we see
some counter evidence for that, then I'd be
fine. Um, the real Dr. Cube, just admit that you really like
Destiny. It's fine. It's okay. I'm It's It's okay.
My only point is that it's fine to call out that is gross behavior.
Gross. I think it's gross, but it's spelled like grace behavior.
But I feel like we just have to accept the fact that I don't
think as many people really care about this. And the chances
of him who's saying anything different. You're like fighting
ghosts right now. Yes. Chances of him realisting are low. Nobody
has said that that would happen. We said that from the beginning
that that wouldn't happen. Very confusing.
It's just in response to him saying that he's already gone through
similar stuff and didn't lose his career. Sure. Okay.
Am I muted now? Nope. What's up? No.
Uh yeah, I mean also people just don't care about victims of
sexual assault in general. There's like multiple in various sports
still have their jobs after beating up their wives allegations
etc. Sir, we are aware that people don't care.
No. Although, you want to know something funny? I don't actually
know if you've heard of this, but Chris Brown has been detained
in England. Have you brought that up at all?
Uh, nope.
So, like a couple of years ago, he like pretty viciously beat
up a guy and then fled the country. And then I guess he either
has amnesia or has like some kind of a team or people around
him that wanted him to get arrested because he organized a tour
in England and thought he could just waltz back here 2 years
later and now he's in um a prison in Manchester.
Wow.
I'm just like that is insane. Like how egotistical do you have
to be to like forget that you like were uh fleeing from the British
police? I don't know. Yeah, pretty great. It's not a nice prison
either. It's not the worst one. Could have been worse, but it's
not great. Um so it's like it's quite funny. Manchester fake
worse than death or is strange ways present there.
Sure. Uh I think if it is determined by
Yeah. I think if it is determined by a court that he didn't purposely
purposefully share stuff or even further purposefully share stuff
maliciously, then people who still hate him after that are no
different than the conservatives on Twitter. Well, he's already
ad See, this is the weird thing is none of these people even
bothered reading any of the documents or anything, right? Like
he literally admitted this. It's in the affidavit that he intentionally
shared these things, right?
Like I feel like a lot of DJs actually think this guy was hacked
still.
crazy. Why read? Destiny told them what to think already. Yeah,
it's basically what it is. It's a little crazy. But we're done.
No, no, no. We're done covering Destiny's legal cases. This is
funny that we just laugh at this. No stakes, no
Uh, it's from the guy who wrote the Echo
Okay, everything is settled. I wish Destiny would start to hold
grudges. See, this is the This is the crazy. This is like uh
average D right here. Yeah, they like want to get revenge. How
long have we hearing this?
Like five years. I think Destiny should hold grudges. Destiny
is too forgiving.
Jtock, what do you think about Destiny being forgiving? JTO,
has he done anything to you? Has he forgave you? J calls me Voldemort.
I think that's quite a good example of a
You could call someone Voldemort if they don't hold a grudge
against them. I don't uh the real Dr. Cube. Yeah, I'm I'm literally
reading comments right here, right? And the I'm reading comments
I'm commenting on comments where they literally don't know what's
been like acknowledged as as fact already. Yeah, exactly.
I didn't even get a single like uh British W, England W from
Jessico after saying Chris Brown was in jail. Not a single response.
I'm sad, but thank you to the chat. Cool. Chris Brown in jail.
Let's go. Let's go. Let's go. Cherry would have engaged me in
this conversation.
Uh, probably. I've got an article we can go over. Distracted.
Yeah, I've got an article we can go over after this, Kelly. Once
we're on to a different topic, I can go to that topic next, actually,
if you want. It sounds like you're Sounds like you're actually
excited about a topic. I'm totally down to go to that next if
you like. I just think it's very funny. I feel like I've spoiled
all of it. Although there are a few funny Tik Toks. I don't know
if I can find them.
Okay. Uh, all right. Never like Pac-Man. He always talks like
he's putting on some sort of a effect, like a radio host persona
or something. Feels super fake. Okay. I just thought this was
I I just thought it was funny. Oh. Oh, wait. Hold on. And then
uh didn't Dean say he didn't want to like Destiny challenged
Dean to a debate and he was like yeah I don't think I want to
associate with Destiny at all as
well. Been a good been a been a rough week. Okay. It's been a
rough week. Been a kind of weird week
to be fair to be fair to Dean as well. Like you fire somebody
and then that some that person goes on Destiny stream. Yeah.
I'm not debating him. I
mean kind of weird.